hey everybody John Luke here bringing
you every ending to pray first we're
going to be showing you these save kalos
one ending which has only one variation
next will be the destroy Tallis one
ending which has three variations you
can either stay behind and die you can
escape on the shuttle if you did the
incapacitate Dahlquist or you can escape
in the escape pod if you did be who is
December quest all of these endings have
differences in dialogue depending on who
is alive and the choices you made
throughout the game finally there's the
post credit scene and it's two endings
where again the dialogue choices change
dramatically depending on your choices
there are time codes in the description
for each ending enjoy
detected
come to the bridge we can finish this
thing once and for all
[Music]
then what you're taking a massive gamble
that there aren't more predators like
the Thailand in the history of the
universe humans have only recently
become somewhere yet you're going to
kick the door open on a much wider and
older cosmic ecology one that feeds on
consciousness these are shark-infested
waters Alex believe we can be the bigger
shot what if we're just foreigners
blood water
what's the update on our hey commander
doll is making a speedy recovery and we
are making our way to the shuttle bay
I've informed him of the threat to the
station I fine Morgan I'll meet you in
the shuttle bay
[Music]
who what Morgan Morgan no you make the
right choice the terminals linked up
again
you should only take a few seconds for a
signal to propagate through the coral
lobotomize every typhoon on Talos one
including the big one outside the rest
of us should get away with a mild
headache I'll let you do the honors but
you better hurry it's not too late we
can still turn this around the prototype
no wave device will work but you have to
hurry
[Music]
you made the right choice the terminal
[Music]
what is the newer mod well it's both an
easy answer complicated one at the same
time it is the future today
more importantly our past today this is
the word Transtar does every employee
working together
it's immortality and it is beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
kill adrenaline and another dose of
Morgan so light
the reactors primed and capable of
delivering close to 30 megatons more
than enough I'll meet you on the bridge
of the last part Murray Morgan there
won't be anything left to detonate
before too late watch me update on our
commander Dahl is making his speedy
recovery and we are making our way to
the shuttle bay I've informed him of the
threat to the station I'm fine Morgan
I'll meet you in the shuttle bay whoo
what am I talking to Morgan Morgan maybe
I see a person who looks like walking
you Morgan be cautious
your brother is unstable he may not
permit you to activate the self-destruct
also he's on unstable is that a joke
operator
you've let this machine poison you did
it tell you it's not gonna let you up
the station
your brother is correct when you destroy
Talos 1 my directive is to ensure that
you perish along with it but you already
knew that it was your idea no one in
their right mind would agree to such a
lunatic plan not true history is
populated with examples of
self-sacrifice for the benefit of others
easy to say when it's not your skin
robot I'm sorry Morgan you have no idea
what that word means I'm gonna put a
stop to this nonsense
your brother is almost done though
obviously once you activate the
self-destruct the point is moot you're
still going to activate the
self-destruct aren't you please recall I
am acting on your orders
it's finished all the directors you gave
me have been completed all except one
when the station detonates it will
destroy the apex Tyson and every trace
of technology derived from it including
you but you know this already it was
your idea after all
the alien Ahmad's you carry would pose
an unacceptable risk to everyone on
earth if you returned
have a seat Morgan you might as well
enjoy the view in your final moment
reactor detonation imminent disorient on
your way I'm not going to make it what
everything's fine I got one of the
escape pods working piece you want
Morgan something's wrong there's no time
trust me
I'll see you aside
[Music]
[Music]
I keep having this dream whoo what organ
Morgan maybe I I see a person who looks
like walking you Morgan be cautious your
brother is unstable he may not permit
you to activate the self-destruct
I knew Morgan never this machine it had
your voice and your for the video you've
done something with operators but this
it's not too late you know we can still
salvage this you change your mind once
you can change it again I won't stop you
if you decide to end it all
I told you I wouldn't so what's it gonna
be
I wish there was something I could have
said to snap you out of this fugue it's
my fault I gambled too much and the
worst part
it isn't losing the station on the tech
it's you I lost my sister that is a
mistake I will never recover from
there's nothing left to talk about if
you have some means of escape you middle
go I will believe in everything I can
about Dyna laundress Oh Morgan oh my god
you're on your own
[Music]
operator deployment
[Music]
we made it look I know what happened
you aren't solely to blame you helped me
and my officers when we needed it I'll
be sure to let earthside know what you
did to help us in the car go doctor you
know it was an honor to work with you
aunt Alice and your brother and thank
you for retrieving lightness remains
Maya always loved the sound of his play
I couldn't let it die with the station
he's was a rare gift and his skill
should be shared not only with me but
with others
now how come the fireworks I hope
they'll be enough you know I thought you
had left the station because of what
happened between us and that I had lied
to you about my condition I was angry
with you and myself but I'm glad you're
here with me now and I like who you have
become you have my father's strength
I thought they wasn't gonna let me in at
first on account of this volunteered get
up thanks again for letting me out
I won't forget it you are a real decent
human being more than you ready or not
stopping keep our operations brief like
check your school gives a [ __ ]
hey aunt your seat this would be a rough
ride
I keep having this dream
who what am I talking to
Morgan Morgan I'm aware that you've
primed the arming keys to destroy
tallest one so I find the activation of
this no wave transmitter station
puzzling the directives you gave me
require I do everything in my power to
ensure you destroy Palos one and all the
Tison detonating the station safe box
and perhaps four let's finish all the
directive you gave me have been
completed all except one when the
station detonates it will destroy the
apex Tyson and every trace of pain
[Music]
[Music]
I keep having this dream
you
let's finished
how did it do
activation of the mirror neurons is
promising empathy quotient shows to be
exceptionally high it probably thinks it
was dreaming and nothing mattered you're
assuming it things like art its life
depends on it
ours too it all comes down to the
choices it made it saved me from the
cargo container I would have suffocated
otherwise and later it recovered alike
my connectomes they were of no practical
use except that they were deeply
meaningful to me it installed multiple
Typhon based neuromas it could mean an
instinctive return to its old kind or
return to integrated dual natures but
its most surprising at was sparing gar
while perhaps for purely selfish reasons
this at least in principle enabled
others to escape Delos why
Michaela I would have died without my
medication that wasn't easy
that says a lot I think about its heart
can I say that it has a heart it also
held my father's records and then I did
not expect this but it let me listen to
them despite the self-incriminating
concept it was willing to make it
nofollow then there was a man inside
cronic Ingram in reading goal was that
mercy
would you let it live
[Music]
yeah
Sara you're next the situation in the
cargo bay was bad none of us would have
survived without himself they destroyed
a large number of Typhon across the
station that has to be a good sign
further afforded those attempt to use us
as hostages if it were one of my
officers I will give it a commendation
Danielle what do you say
it found me it doesn't need to but it
did I asked it to stop volunteer or 37
God was dangerous no way to be sure but
I think it has a sense of retribution a
lot of humans controlled by the Tison
ended up dead not that it was easy to
avoid but I think it's worth the risk in
the end he chose to destroy tell us why
why to protect that we can't really know
what its motives were for anything it
did but we have to make a choice you can
hear us
can't you here I want to show you
something
[Music]
but you're experienced was a
reconstruction based on Morgan's
memories
this is the wall today
you spend years trying to put what you
can do into us we never tried putting
what we can do into you until now you're
the bridge between our species I need to
know if you see us I mean really see us
take my hand if you do
[Music]
we're going to shake things up like old
times
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]